so Mark Andrews what happened with you
were making a point with Mark Andrews on
the fact that they're coming back and
they're suing you know you for the dark
what point were you gonna make with him
well Mark and Mark Andrews is simply
saying I'm not a quote mule he's not
even disputing necessarily that the
movie is inaccurate he's simply saying
he was wrongly identified as a mule out
of 2000 only one is suing you only one
but so so so okay did you did you hear
that Tom loud and clear out of 2 000
only one is suing you
that that is that's not good for the
other side yeah why isn't there someone
like a Gloria Allred who's really good
at rounding up women on hashtag me too
and putting five of them in front of the
camera why isn't there a a a a leftist
lawyer like that rounding up people to
do it I that's what I'm thinking like a
class action lawsuit or something yeah
we show a lot that's kind of shocked to
clarify did you name two thousand mules
did you just name Mark Andrews like how
how did Mark Andrews find out that he
was in the documentary did you name him
specifically do you name other people no
we don't name any mules
um remember one thing to tell you about
Geo tracking when you sell when you Geo
track people's phones you don't get
their names you get the ID of their
phones okay so for example all our
phones have a unique ID it's not the
phone number but it's in our phone and
so if you run a Geo tracking search
let's just say for example and by the
way this is how good this technology is
if somebody is murdered in Piedmont Park
in Atlanta in the middle of the night no
eyewitnesses all you have is a body
first thing the cops do they run a
geofence around that Park and they look
for all the cell phone devices in that
Park and what they get is the cell phone
ID now they have to go to a judge and
the judge will give you a warrant and
then you go to the cell phone provider
and they give you the names phone
numbers and addresses of all those
people then you can go talk to them now
one of the ways you know that somebody's
making an honest documentary is you say
all right I'm gonna we have all these
two thousand meals in their cell phone
IDs we're willing to give this to any
law enforcement that wants it right all
you have to do is go interview the mules
and ask them who paid you who gave you
those ballots who organized this
operation so I'm calling for for this
I'm willing to put my thesis on the line
and if I'm wrong go interview the mules
and they'll have an innocent explanation
they'll be like oh man we're all like
Mark Andrews we're all just dropping off
the ballots of our family members it's
all on the up and up Dinesh has nothing
here but they don't want to do that so
and the left doesn't want them to do
that fill a bump of the Washington Post
was written like 20 articles on 2000
mules he's like he's scared of law
enforcement going go go go to the
left-wing non-profits and ask them Hey
listen you got all this money to get out
the vote can we see your records to see
if you've been organizing these mules
are you providing ballots where are you
getting them no there in other words
when someone is trying to block the
investigation from moving forward I
would say that's on the that's Prima
fishy suspicious so so so here's here's
why I'm asking a question so check this
out DeSean Watson first person comes out
right remember it's like well you know I
was giving him a massage and then you
remember you and I were talking about it
because yeah he's a guy I wanted to buy
his best card so I'm like hey what's the
story all about and then he's like wow
all you may want to hold off because the
second person came in and the third
person came out and a fourth and a fifth
eventually was what 28. well guess what
at about 20 something do you believe
that that actually happened with DeSean
right after all those allegations yeah
so there's five yeah so you're Ellen
DeGeneres she's a very tough person to
work with as a boss she's a one person
two people ten people okay probably
she's got high expectations and it's
tough to work with right you know
coaches you would hear stories to only
have one of two thousand come out it's a
little weird let me give you the other
part the other part so you know the
whole 81 million votes let's play that
you know to say your argument is wrong
two thousand meals you're just kind of
doing a favor for Trump come on Dinesh
let's face it I mean obviously great
opportunity you made a lot of money if
20 million people watch it they pay 20
bucks you make good money good for you
this is a big victory for you if we're
going to dinner tonight you're paying
for it we're getting a nice bottle of
wine but aside from that if Democrats
are sitting there saying guys
do us a favor
help Biden win
allow us to have the Senate allow us to
have the house we're going to show you
that Russia was behind this with Trump
okay so then Democrats are like what
hell yeah
if this guy really did do something with
Russia guess what let's take him down
I'm going to vote Democrat and then you
vote Democrat six months goes by 12
months goes by 24 months goes by
nothing's going on there here's the
scary part
if and they've all been saying the same
thing if Republicans win the house and
the Senate their biggest fear is some of
these investigations may actually start
and that's why some of these guys on the
other side like you heard what Hillary
said if you want to post what Hillary
just recently said a story that you know
you can't talk here's Hillary Hillary
Clinton GOP has planned to literally
steal 2024 election it's kind of weird
that she gets away with saying this kind
of stuff and she said this on what she
said this on an interview what was the
context of this one like this this was
like a week ago right yeah a couple
weeks ago yeah Hillary GOP has literally
planned plan to literally steal 2024
election she's been saying this Pelosi
said it back in the days even the
speaker uh what do you call it the
person that represents yeah she said
that and that came up and uh but but if
but if what you're saying is true if you
have enough you know to show data do you
think if the right wins uh Senate and
the house they're gonna go investigate
2020 elections or no well I I hope that
they do I know there are some
congressmen and Senators who will push
for it but I will also say that I've
detected this has been maybe my greatest
frustration with this film has been that
there is a sort of a GOP establishment
right and their view is uh let's move on
Dinesh why are you making this film
let's not look in the rear view mirror
we need to move on and part of it is
that these guys are not entirely unhappy
that Trump lost in 2020. in other words
their view is that Hey listen if Trump
and the Republicans both got clobbered
that'd be really bad but Trump lost but
the Republicans down ballot did pretty
well so here is their scheme that is
Biden's gonna come and he's going to be
horrible there's going to be a public
Revolt throw the Democrats out and the
Republicans come back in but without
Trump so there's a sort of a republican
feeling that 2020 the 2000 mules is kind
of spoiling the Republican picnic right
now like Dinesh is not cooperating with
the team so I want them to have these
hearings I think we should get to the
bottom of it and again you know this is
all a case where if there's nothing to
it show us so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one and click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]